ما مدى دعم إيران للحوثيين من وجهة نظر
المملكة
، مدى أه واسع
وحاسم للغاية في المجهود الحربي
، الصواريخ الباليستية وتكنولوجيا الطائرات بدون طيار
هي
بالكامل من أصل إيراني مما أدى حتى
الآن
إلى أكثر من 400
الطائرات بدون طيار التي يتم إطلاقها عبر
الحدود وتضرب أهدافًا مثل مستودعات الوقود
والمطارات أهدافًا مدنية أخرى ،
ونعتقد أنه بدون دعم
إيران
ومستشاريها الموجودين على الأرض ،
لن يتمكن الحوثيون من شن هذه
الهجمات ضد
البنية التحتية المدنية السعودية
وسيكونون مقيدين
في محاولاتهم لمواصلة مهاجمة
أجزاء أخرى من
اليمن والاستيلاء على البلاد إلى
جانب إسرائيل والإمارات
، قالت المملكة العربية السعودية بوضوح
شديد إنها تريد أي
صفقة جديدة قد تبرمها الولايات المتحدة مع إيران
لتشمل قيودًا على
برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية و  دعمها
لمجموعات الميليشيات في
جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط ، ليس أقلها في
اليمن مدى ثقتك في إيران
قد توافق على هذه الشروط أو أنها
ستشكل جزءًا من هذه المناقشات المبكرة
التي تجري الآن
خلف أبواب مغلقة ، كما
نفهم ، نعتقد أنه من المهم للغاية
معالجة هذه القضايا ،
نرى عمليات تسليم
الصواريخ الباليستية إلى صواريخ الحوثيين الباليستية.
وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ الباليستية
للحوثيين وغيرهم
من الفاعلين غير الحكوميين
كمصدر حاسم لعدم الاستقرار
في المنطقة
أيضًا بالطبع أه الدعم العام
للميليشيات وفاعلين من غير الدول كل
هذا حقًا ما يتسبب
في استمرار هذه المنطقة  في دورة
أه أه من التوتر والتصعيد المحتمل
، الطريقة الوحيدة التي سنحصل بها على
منطقة سلمية ومنطقة آمنة
هي إذا تعاملنا مع هذه المخاوف
ونعتقد بالتأكيد أنه من المهم للغاية
أن
تصعد إيران وتلتزم بالتزامها
الإقليمي  الاستقرار
والأمن بالانسحاب من أه دعم هؤلاء
الفاعلين غير الحكوميين حسناً قلتم مراراً وتكراراً
المملكة العربية السعودية
يجب التشاور مع هيئة الطيران المدني ودول الخليج بشكل كامل خلال أي إعادة تفاوض بشأن
رئيس لجنة العلاقات الخارجية الفرنسية ، قال ماكرون الفرنسي في
يناير / كانون الثاني إنه يود أن يرى
المملكة العربية السعودية تشارك بشكل مباشر في
محادثات طهران وقد أوضح بوضوح
أن هذا الأمر غير مطروح
للتفاوض بشأن ذلك.  لا يحدث
ما هي التأكيدات ،
إن وجدت ، التي تحصل عليها من إدارة بايدن
والأوروبيين الآخرين أم
أن المملكة ستثير
مخاوفها خلال أي مفاوضات مستقبلية
لـ JCPOA ،
لذا دعني أوضح البلدان
الأكثر عرضة لخطر
إيران المسلحة نوويًا  دول أخرى
في المنطقة
بما في ذلك بالطبع المملكة
العربية السعودية ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ،
لذا فمن المنطقي تمامًا أن
نكون جزءًا من المناقشة وجزءًا من
الحوار ونسمع من شركائي الأوروبيين
والأمريكيين أنهم يفهمون
أن مخاوف
يجب التعامل مع دول المنطقة
ويجب أن يكون لنا دور في تلك
المناقشات وفي تلك المفاوضات التي
نحن فيها  حوار الآن مع
شركائنا الدوليين أه كيف
يمكن معالجة دورنا ومخاوفنا أه في تلك المناقشات نعتقد أننا
يجب أن نكون على الطاولة كما قلت
نحن أكبر تهديد للبلاد
وبالتالي فمن الصواب أن  كن
أه على الطاولة وطبعًا أه إيران
قالت مرارًا وتكرارًا إنها مهتمة
بإجراء حوار مع جيرانها
حول الأمن
الإقليمي وما ليس موضوعًا للأمن الإقليمي
إن لم يكن
الموضوع النووي إذاً إذا أرادت إيران إجراء
حوار معنا  هذا
جيد ولكننا نعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون لدينا هذا
الحوار كجزء من المناقشات
مقابل jcpoa
ويمكن أن يساعد ذلك بعد ذلك في تهدئة
مخاوفنا إلى حد كبير إذا كنا
على الطاولة سنرى أننا نأمل أن
ترى إيران
تعود للامتثال وتوافق على
معالجة المخاوف التي لدينا على حد سواء
حول
أه القصور في بنية أه سابقًا
لكن أيضًا بالطبع
أه استقرار أه إقليمي وأه
صواريخ باليستية وغيرها أنا
خلاصة القول ، ما مدى واقعية أنه يمكنك
أن تكون على نفس طاولة المفاوضات
مع الإيرانيين في أي مفاوضات jcpoa ،
نعم أعتقد أنه من الواقعي تمامًا
أننا قد قلنا أنها ستضمن
أن دفاعات المملكة
قوية بحيث يمكنها الدفاع عن
نفسها  كدولة ذات سيادة تمامًا كما
تقول أيضًا بالطبع إنها بحاجة إلى إعادة ضبط
علاقتها
معك ، أتساءل ما الذي قد
تتخيله الآن كهيكل أمني إقليمي جديد
ومدى أهمية الدور الذي يمكن أن
نلعبه في المضي قدمًا في هيكل الأمن الإقليمي الجديد هذا.
أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة لديها مصالح حيوية
في المنطقة وستظل لها
مصلحة حيوية في المنطقة ، لذلك
أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة
ستواصل المشاركة بنشاط في
ضمان أمن واستقرار
المنطقة التي قلنا عنها في المنطقة من أجل
بعض الوقت الآن
نريد أن نلعب دورًا أكبر في
ضمان
أمننا وأمن
المنطقة الأوسع ، ونحن مستعدون
للتدخل  ع ونحن على استعداد
للتصعيد أه لكننا نريد أن نفعل ذلك بالتعاون
والتنسيق مع شركائنا
الدوليين وبالدرجة الأولى بالطبع الولايات المتحدة
لذلك
سنجري هذا الحوار في تلك
المناقشة وأعتقد
أنه شيء نحن عليه  منفتحة للغاية
لأننا كما قلت ، أردنا دائمًا
أه أو أردنا لبعض الوقت أن
أه تعلم أن نعمل معًا للعب دور أكبر
في أمننا ، لذا
أعتقد أن هذا هو الاتجاه الذي نسير فيه
هل تسعى
تقارب مع طهران في هذه
المرحلة
نسعى لإيران إلى أه هذا أه تعلمون
فقط
أوقفوا أنشطتها أه التي تسبب
أه أه
عدم الاستقرار أه في المنطقة إنها
سلوكياتها العدوانية
طبعاً لو كانت مستعدة
لذلك أه هذا
سيفتح  رفع الأبواب ليس فقط
للإبلاغ عن المزيد ولكن حتى التعاون ولكن
لا يمكننا الحصول على تقرير أكثر من دون
معالجة أه
هذه التهديدات الشديدة جدًا أه على
الاستقرار الإقليمي والأمن
من لبنان إلى سوريا إلى العراق إلى اليمن
وكذلك الانقلاب  أنشطة rse
داخل دول المنطقة بما في ذلك
السعودية لتزويد
الإرهابيين بمعدات صنع القنابل
بأشياء من هذا القبيل
حتى إذا كانت إيران مستعدة للتراجع عن
ذلك أه ترغب في معاملة
أه أه المنطقة أه دول
المنطقة باحترام واه
بدونك  أعرف أه تعامل أه مع أه
أه أو حاول تعزيز نفوذه من
خلال القنوات العادية من
خلال نشاط الدولة إلى الدولة ،
فأعتقد أن هذا شيء
يمكننا أن نأمله لأنه بالتأكيد شيء
نود رؤيته لأن
إيران في النهاية جزء من المنطقة
و  سيبقى جزءًا من
المنطقة التي
نحن في المملكة أه نريد التركيز على
تنميتنا الخاصة نريد أن نركز على
برنامج الإصلاح الاقتصادي الطموح أه لدينا
نريد التركيز على
تحقيق أه الرخاء المستدام
للشعب السعودي
وهذا بالطبع يمكن فقط
تعززها الاستقرار في المنطقة
والتعاون مع إيران ، لكن ذلك
يتطلب من
إيران تغيير سلوكها.
الأطراف في لبنان
تتفق بشكل عاجل على حكومة
جديدة وإنقاذ البلاد من
الانهيار المالي بعد
شهور من
الشلل السياسي الآن حزب الله
يوسع دوره
في لبنان فقط في أعقاب ما كان
هذا الفراغ في القيادة ،
ما هو الدور إن وجد؟  هل
تخطط المملكة للعب في لبنان المضي قدما في
اللجوء
لاستعادة بعض الشعور بالاستقرار السياسي
لبنان في يد
اللبنانيين نتمنى أن تأخذ
القيادات
اللبنانية واللبنانية والهيئة السياسية اللبنانية
نظرة حقيقية أه جادة
على  الوضع
لبنان يتحد ويتبنى إصلاحات حقيقية من
خلال إصلاحات سياسية
إصلاحات اقتصادية يمكن أن
تتصدى للتحديات التي يواجهها لبنان
ويمكن أن تقدم
أه أه حلول مستدامة
للمستقبل
ما لم يكن اللبنانيون أه سياسي أه
القيادة على استعداد للقيام بذلك أه
أخشى أن لبنان  يتجه نحو
ظروف أكثر خطورة من أي وقت مضى
والوضع الراهن
في لبنان لم يعد قابلاً للتطبيق أ  و
لا تشعر المملكة أنه من
المناسب الاستمرار في
الدعم أو الاستمرار في دعم
أه الوضع الراهن الذي كما ذكرتم
أوجد أه فاعل غير حكومي لديه حزب الله
بحكم الأمر الواقع
أه على أه أه الفيتو على
كل ما يحدث  في ذلك البلد
ويسيطر على
بنيته التحتية الرئيسية وأشياء من
هذا القبيل بينما
أه الطبقة السياسية لا تفعل سوى القليل
جدًا لمواجهة التحديات
التي يواجهها المواطنون اللبنانيون العاديون ، لذا
فأنت تعرف ما إذا كان الفساد مستشريًا
أم
سوء إدارة كل هذه الأشياء
يحتاجها لبنان
أجندة إصلاحية حقيقية أه ونتمنى
أن يجتمع السياسيون
اللبنانيون ويتبنون مثل هذه الأجندة وإذا فعلوا
سنقف هناك لدعمهم
ونوفر
أجندة الإصلاح التي دعمته المملكة العربية السعودية بالطبع
في الماضي فهل أنتم مستعدون لذلك؟
بأننا مستعدين للمضي قدمًا لدعم
أجندة إصلاح قوية جدًا وحقيقية
أه نتمنى أن يتمكن أه الأسد
والآخرون من تحقيق ذلك
إذا  أي أجندة إصلاحية حقيقية أه أه
أجندة إصلاحية من أي شخص في
لبنان سنقف وراء أننا لسنا
أه نقف وراء أفراد في
لبنان
سنكون جاهزين للوقوف وراء لبنان طالما
أن الطبقة السياسية اللبنانية تتخذ
خطوات حقيقية للتصدي
أه أه  المشاكل التي أه لبنان
لبنان يواجهها ما هو موقف السعودية
من سوريا اليوم وهل هناك الآن خطط
للتواصل
مع الرئيس بشار الأسد
هناك عملية من خلالكم تعرفون
التي ترعاها الأمم المتحدة
حيث تتعامل المعارضة مع
حكومة  أه بشار الأسد
نؤيد تلك العملية نتمنى
أه أن تتخذ حكومة
بشار الأسد
أه الخطوات المناسبة أه
لتمكين حل سياسي لأن
هذا هو السبيل الوحيد للأمام
في سوريا نحتاج إلى استقرار سوريا
وهذا يتطلب التنازل عنها  مراجعة
أه التسوية من قبل أه
الحكومة
السورية وتقتضي اجتمعا بين
أه الحكومة والمعارضة
أه لتتمكن من المضي قدما في
عملية سياسية يمكن أن توفر ذلك
الاستقرار اللازم
وسنواصل دعم أه أه أن
عملية أه الأمم تدعمون الإمارات
التي تطالب برفع
العقوبات المفروضة على النظام في سوريا
بموجب قانون
القيصر بفعل القيصر  بالطبع
شيء أهنا أخذناه أه
بخصوص أه موقفها من أه
سوريا وأعتقد أه
المهم أن نعالج
القضية الجوهرية وهي إيجاد
حل سياسي بدون ذلك
لن نكون قادرين على المضي
قدمًا  لذلك نحن نركز على دفع
العملية السياسية إلى الأمام ومن ثم
دعمنا
نحن مبعوث الأمم المتحدة وجهوده لتحقيق
ذلك